[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
ryan nicodemus is out on vacation this
week but don't worry we got alabama here
hi everybody we got tk coleman hey hey
oh we got a special guest too coming up
today on this free
public minimal episode we're joined by
the philosopher and radical theologian
peter rollins and together we're going
to talk to a listener about misery and
letting go of trauma we also have an
outstanding lightning round listener tip
and added value segment for you you can
check out the full three hour maximal
conversation of episode 354 where we
answer four times the questions and we
dive deep into seven simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at theminimalists.com
private your support keeps our podcast
and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck alabama what do you
got for us our first question today
comes from jessica in denver colorado
my question may sound silly and before i
ask it i want you to know that i get so
much value from your work but i
sometimes wonder why why are you so
compelled to help people who are wired
this way
what is your biggest challenge and what
is your biggest takeaway
i'm interested in the answer to this
question and jessica by the way i love
this question let me tell you why i love
the question
because it's a difficult question
i could make it sound easy there's a
narrative overlay where oh i want to
help people or or whatever but really
the question is the why
behind that you're ready for the money
well on the field the advertisements
suck part
yeah i mean
that would be true if we just peppered
this whole thing with advertisement
um i'm not allergic to money either
though and so i don't want to renounce
that i don't even want to renounce
advertisements i'm just kind of grossed
out by them i mean i am sponsored by
bob's auto mechanics today
so i'd be interested i'll give my sort
of narrative overlay of this whole thing
jessica because i know you're asking me
and ryan isn't here today but i'm
interested in some different answers
here so
i think we'll get a bit existential here
with peter in a moment but tk i thought
we would start with you why do you do
what you do you you help people you feel
a desire to create things that help
people
why do you do what you do
one of the things i said last week when
we were talking about why
we decided to do this is a principle
that i govern my life by when it comes
to decision making and that is in the
absence of any logically or morally
compelling reason to do otherwise
always do what feels good to you
always do what feels fun to you now
there are some logical reasons for why
something might feel fun and you say i'm
not going to do that there are some
morally compelling reasons for why
something might give you pleasure and
you say i'm not going to do that but in
the absence of that you do what brings
you joy and so for me
work like this helping people it's not
because i'm a saint it's not because one
day i was busy doing something else and
then the voice of god said
tk i want you to go podcast and help
people it was no i've always enjoyed
work that was like this even in a
different context i've always enjoyed
advocating for other people's
possibilities i've i've always you know
you know i've heard it said before that
one of the best ways to figure out what
makes you come alive is to figure out
what pisses you off what irritates you
what annoys you because that gives you
valuable information about what you're
hardwired to change the kinds of
problems you're likely to enjoy solving
and when i was a kid i always got
irritated when i saw someone who had
more possibilities than they believed in
and whenever i saw someone with a
self-defeating belief
and living a life where they were
stressed out overwhelmed sad all the
time because they didn't see the
possibilities they had i always enjoyed
the game of trying to
convince them that they had the
permission and the power to be the
predominant creative force in their own
lives and so i'm playing that game i
enjoy doing this kind of work i'm not
convinced that like it's the only thing
that i could do or it's the one right
thing for me to do or that it's morally
good it's just it's what i enjoy it's
like playing basketball and playing the
piano pete i brought you on the podcast
a few months ago to talk about suffering
another joyous topic
and
what i've learned is that healing is
often at the terminus of suffering or
suffering can lead to
healing in some way and so i think if i
were to give a sort of
answer that
comports with how i feel today is it
feels good to see people heal and
sometimes when i create something
it helps someone heal their relationship
with their stuff their relationship with
their clinging their relationship with
other people their relationship with
money and healing those relationships
not fixing them not repairing them
but actually seeing that healing within
someone and it feels good for me so this
isn't completely altruistic either and i
want to be clear about that what i do
isn't oh i'm just serving the greater
good yes but it also feels good to serve
the greater good in some respect but i'm
interested why do you do what you do
because you're a radical theologian
you're a philosopher and you sometimes
share some things that are considered to
be controversial and it seems to me to
be easier to just not share those things
at all yes oh yeah it's a good question
i was first of all thinking what do i do
and then after then why do i do it um
but you've said it very well actually i
have to write that down next time
someone asked me what i do
radical theologian philosopher um
you know i was reminded there's a of a
story of a guy who um goes on a sea
voyage and he washes up on this uh shore
and he goes into this tine and he starts
to preach and he preaches this message
and at first lots of people listen to
him but after he's been there for a few
months he becomes you know pretty new
and people stop paying attention but
still this guy keeps preaching his
message and eventually someone comes up
to him and says you know like no one's
listening to you why do you keep singing
this song why do you keep preaching this
message when it's obvious that nobody
really is paying attention
and he said
well at first i thought i was doing it
for the people but he said then i
realized that the message i preach is
for myself
and that's kind of how i feel about a
lot of our work is that our work is
often a way of self-healing uh you know
reminding ourselves of something or
speaking to some dimension of ourselves
so for example if i'm always talking
about how to embrace lack how to kind of
like uh
get free from frenetic pursuits of kind
of whatever i go like well maybe i'm the
i'm the the person who needs to receive
the message just like if you write a
love letter uh often you don't even have
to send it because you think you're
writing it for somebody else but you're
really writing it for yourself so and
even if you do send it you probably read
it 10 times 20 times the other person
might read it once
because the love letter always lacan
says reaches its destination because
it's destination is not the other as
such but but in a sense it's yourself
it's beautiful i so good i think
about i teach a writing class how to
write better.org it's an online writing
class and what i learned i started
teaching that a decade ago back in 2012
and i noticed especially the first two
or three years my writing improved
dramatically from teaching the writing
class because in a way i was i was
beginning to i had to pause it's like a
baker who bakes a cake and they don't
know how they do it if they need to give
someone else the recipe they have to
stop and say i need this much flour i
need to do it in this sequence i need to
bake it at this temperature this much
sugar this much chocolate goes into the
cake but they may not know that before
and what they do is they start to refine
it based on the experience of actually
teaching that to someone else so in a
way
by teaching this to other people i think
the person that has improved and healed
most is me yes and if other people go
out there and they i've noticed that
people tend to share what we do on the
podcast that's why we we do all of these
tick tock clips and instagram clips is
because as you start to share something
do we have to do some dance tech talks
it's gonna be great okay all right
you're gonna have to teach me the moves
because i watch a lot of them but i'm
not very good at them so
wait till the end of this you're going
to look great
we're going to remix just that moment
right now
anyway jessica i'd love to send you a
copy of our book love people use things
it's about healing the seven essential
relationships in our lives ryan and i
wrote this
we finished it during the pandemic and
what i realized in a way this was a
pandemic preparation manual
but in the sense that we are going
through our own individual pandemics we
have all of these tragedies with our
finances so healing the relationship
with our money healing our relationship
with our values with our self
with other people with our stuff and so
i'd love to send you a audio book
version if you like our podcast you'll
enjoy the audio book of love people use
things or if you want the book book or
the ebook be happy to send those to you
as well jessica malabama will reach out
to you and get you a copy of that book
by the way you know what time it is in
alabama yes i do it's 10 44. no no it's
uh time for the lightning round
this is where we answer your questions
uh from well your text message questions
937-202-4654 you can text your questions
your comments those texts go right to
our phone so we respond to you on the
podcast or maybe even via our phone
olivia has a question for us
how do you avoid the regret of not
getting the best souvenirs for your
loved ones after a recent holiday i came
back feeling guilty for not bringing
special items to give to relatives that
weren't able to go with me now pete you
probably remember this we tried to do
our best during the lightning round to
answer questions with a short shareable
less than 140 character response we put
the text to these minimal maxims in the
show notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com i have something pithy
and then we can just unpack it because i
was talking to tk about this yesterday
you had something great on this as well
but here is so i was walking through
my new town that i moved up to in
ventura county and we were walking
around with my wife yesterday and i saw
this
consignment shop
and i
peeked in the window there were clothes
bex and i were sort of looking like two
kids at christmas in the window
and i saw just so much junk in this
consignment shop and there's this old
appleton that one man's junk is another
man's treasure but i think i'd like to
update that for today's standards and so
here's something pithy for you one man's
junk
is usually another man's junk too
and so these people were trying to get
rid of their things and occasionally
someone might find a treasure in there
but quite often the things that we're
holding on to
we continue to hold on to it even though
it's junk thinking oh someday someone
might get something out of this but the
truth is most of the things that we have
amassed aren't going to add value to
most people in our lives i think that's
certainly true with souvenirs whenever
we travel somewhere in fact i was going
to try and get ryan on the phone to
answer this question with us he's up in
yellowstone right now and he has no
phone service and so i couldn't even get
him to phone it in
and uh anyway
it took me a minute yeah it took me a
minute i don't want that comedic genius
to go unappreciated but i i don't want
the audience to think about the truck
i also had a lag
i'm just slow man but it was good
so so what i'll tell you though is he is
collecting something there it may not be
souvenirs it may not be fridge magnets
or postcards or little plastic
statuettes that are made in china
that was my the most fun thing when i
went to um
uh i i saw mount rushmore for the first
time but their entire cities predicated
on
selling you like made in china figurines
of mount rushmore
and what i noticed is that oh this is
just junk and we in the moment think we
want the thing but after the fact that
desire to possess the thing doesn't just
dissipate but it's completely gone and
we wonder why did i even want to pick
this up in the first place but you do
pick up something different tk
you want my python you want me to
comment on that yeah yeah okay let's get
short let's get attenuated okay okay so
my
sometimes the the best gift is a good
story
if you think about this is the unpack if
you think about what it what a gift is
it's really
a form of crystallized appreciation it's
an effort to say i like you i love you
or i see you in the form of an artifact
right here's a little golden coin here's
a pen that i got out of a gift shop
here's a button and it's a physical
thing that concretizes this intangible
sentiment that i feel towards you and so
what makes people appreciate a gift
is the thought that's behind it which is
why we say it's the thought that counts
and we can prove this to ourselves
because if you take important days like
anniversaries or valentine's day
birthdays whatever and i know the
importance of these days are all
arbitrary but
if you just try to money your way into
appreciation by writing people checks or
giving them cash
they'll feel cheap
even if the month the money you're
giving them exceeds the monetary value
of a creative gift and why is that
because people know the difference
between something that requires the
input of energy thought and time versus
you just trying to buy your way out of
something or buy your way into a
friendship no one wants to feel like
they're being bought they want to feel
like you did something that made you
really think about them so when you take
the time to put together a playlist of
songs on spotify right tk this episode
was brought to you by not spotify
and you say here's a playlist of songs
that reminded me of you
people say wow man
thank you that means a lot because you
really had to think about them and put
some time into that even though you
spent no money on them versus just
buying them something because it was
expensive like you're trying to impress
them with a price tag
so how can you use that observation to
overcome this fear that when you go out
of town you're not getting something
nice for the people that you love well
since it's the thought that counts give
them the gift of thought when you come
home
write them a letter it doesn't have to
be more than one page but take some time
to think about an experience that you
had a place that you visited a
conversation that you had something you
observed that made them think of you
and tell them a little story about how
you felt like they were with you in
spirit while you were on the road and
how you saw this clock or you met this
person in a coffee shop and they said
something that made you think about them
and how much they mean to you and you
wish that they could have been there and
you hope that maybe one day they'll be
able to go there with you in the future
but even if they can't they were with
you through that moment i guarantee you
people are going to remember something
like that much longer than they would a
button that they'll eventually throw
away and by the way if your friendships
require you to buy expensive gifts in
order to maintain them the friendship is
already dead
lovely
can i can i long or short yes
on this one i can only do long
short long i'm a lighty yeah okay it
could be long
yes if it's good well that's not gonna
be gonna do anything
um
i was thinking of like when you were
talking uh there's a very famous frieze
by freud a lot of people know is near
the end of his life he wrote this letter
and in the letter he said what does a
woman want right and there's even a
movie called what does what does women
want or something with mel gibson so
this is a famous phrase of freud what
does a woman want
and a lot of people see this as freud
going just not understanding women or
whatever but
he was actually one way of understanding
what he was doing
uh and what he meant by that phrase
is he noticed something that was
more obvious
in feminine structure than masculine
structures and then what uh later french
psychoanalysts did is they they showed
how this question is what do people want
so what does women want led to what do
men want what do all of us want and what
freud noticed which is very interesting
was he noticed that um
a lot of the women he was talking to
uh what they desired
is what the other desired so in terms of
even fantasy life men's fantasies are
often very
solidified right sedimented so a man
might have a certain fantasy but women's
fantasies were often not so solidified
much more fluid so for example a man
might say to his partner i'd love
someone to watch us having sex right and
the woman might go
i've never thought about that and oh i
don't really like the idea
but then she might go
well i see that you like the thought so
let's whisper about it let's talk about
that's right and then as they talk about
it
in discourse
she starts to enjoy the desire that it
evokes in him and then she starts to go
i quite like this idea and then maybe
even they they do it and then after they
break up she goes off and this desire is
hers now but but what was interesting is
that
the desire for sleeping was having sex
when someone's watching wasn't what she
desired she desired the desire that
animated that act right
um so freud noticed this and noticed
that our our desires are so
interconnected with the desire of the
other
and then then men's desire exactly the
same it just kind of plays out in a
different way
so all of this to kind of like back up
exactly what you're saying is
a gift and somebody bought me a little
wooden thing oh sorry uh recently a
little kind of uh that
souvenir that meant a lot because there
was desire within it it was the object
was the representation but it
represented this this desire that that
animated up which is what lacan calls
object object a
so in terms of this question all of that
comes right into exactly what you're
saying is that
what can one do
to concretize one's desire and a letter
is a good example floors for example
because floors are no pragmatic value so
why do we like things like floors why do
we like things that literally have no
use value
because in a sense when you when you
give something like this little wooden
object i was given it's got no use value
at all
so it kind of in a sense is a great
receptacle
of the desire of the other
those are the kind of little objects
that are special yeah so i think where
we go with this olivia and thanks for
your question
is instead of bringing home souvenirs
for people
you should watch them have sex
yes that's the takeaway
hey josh who was that writer who said
something like uh
forgive me for writing a letter that so
long i didn't have time to make it short
it's often attributed to
uh mark twain samuel clemens yeah um and
the reason that we do that or the reason
that we often write something that is so
verbose is because we didn't have time
to attenuate it to edit it to make it
something pithy and short but what i
like about this segment is it allows us
to do both to have something pithy but
then also let's expand on it in a way
that is meaningful and my pithy response
is you're too nice just forget about
everybody else and have a good time okay
so that's my short one the long one was
about the desire of the other's desire
but the short one is just just enjoy
yourself don't worry about them alabama
we got so much more to talk about today
but what do you got for us first here's
a minimalist insight from one of our
listeners
hello my name is amberly i'm from
louisiana and i wanted to tell y'all
about um a company that i find a lot of
value in um it's called united by blue
and they um i'm not getting anything
from them for saying this i just really
enjoyed the company i bought a backpack
from them
a couple years ago and
i love it it's really great and i'm
finding a lot of value in it
they have quality products they're very
environmentally friendly and they take a
pound of trash out of the ocean for
every project that you buy thank you and
thanks for everything y'all do you all
are great
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing going on in the life of
the minimalists how let's describe this
to peter in a way that will resonate
with him because what we're doing here
is we're doing something called sunday
symposium and we're doing this once a
month in los angeles you were at our
last los angeles event yeah it was an
amazing event this gathering of people
some really vulnerable open honest
questions and so we want to recreate
that in a way tk's been out on tour with
us and we've done a bunch of different
cities together ryan and i have done 10
different tours over the last 12 years
and what we really what we realized
there is that sense of community
connection meaning
purpose when we break down the walls of
the the glowing screen the glowing
screen's nice it enables us to
communicate with a lot of people but
this goes a step
further and so tk if you were to explain
the sunday symposium
to peter to try to entice him to maybe
come to our second or third one he maybe
he can be our special guest there what
would you tell him
it's like going to church without
everything you hate about going to
church
when people go to church
you can't really define that by just one
thing right is it the sermon or the
homily yeah it's about that there's
somebody that's gonna do some talking
about life and maybe a little philosophy
and a little comedy is it about the
people that are there yeah there's going
to be some of that and some opportunity
to connect with them you know um it's is
it about the music and the singing yeah
there's going to be some of that but you
can't reduce it to any one of those
things because if you do all you got is
a lecture or all you got is a concert
all you got is a stand-up routine
it's it's the magic that happens
when you bring people together
with a combination of structure and
spontaneity and say here's what we're
gonna do
but we're gonna do it together playfully
with an effort to see what we can
discover and this is born
out of a
out of a need to
you know get out of our homes and have a
reason to go out which is what we're all
looking for but without having to rely
on conventional excuses you know i often
think of you know
men getting together and going to the
bar to watch sports is just a way to say
i love you brother without being so
direct about it and sometimes we want to
say hey i love you brother or i want to
connect with you sister and the only way
we have to do it is be like let's go to
the bar let's go to the shopping mall
let's go to a movie and we both stare at
the same screen but we never say
anything to each other we want to give
people a space where they can come to
and do those things and be as direct as
they want to be but also be as indirect
as they want to be yeah
peter we're doing these once a month
we're calling them sunday symposiums or
sundays at noon
and uh we'd love for you to join us at
one of them so we're soliciting you live
on air absolutely yeah to see if we can
get you there now the first one we
announced uh is august 28th it filled up
in an hour so uh we have free tickets or
purchase tickets if you want to help us
pay for the venue it's at a beautiful
venue this guy named jamie and his wife
they own is called dynasty typewriter
downtown los angeles filled up in an
hour but get yourself on the wait list
so you can hear about the future events
we're going to do this every month where
you show up and we you called it a
church without religion in a way right
because although it's religious in
another sense this is the something that
pete taught me is the religion the the
root of that is uh liturgy or ligament
to bind things together what do you love
about the live events oh yeah and i yeah
i i started off with live events before
i started writing books bringing people
together
um
i'll say yeah one thing is if
if we could do this stuff without art
and music and community that would be
great i would say don't don't meet up
you know whatever but
the problem is we we do need arts and
music and spoken word in order to help
us and so we basically were liturgical
creatures there's the old story about
this guy who thinks uh thinks he's um
seat literally thinks he's seated on the
ground and he goes to a psychoanalyst
and after a year of psychoanalysis he
realizes he's not seat he's a human
being right i'm a human being and he
leaves and uh about a month later he's
comes back and he's knocking on the
analyst door the analyst opens the door
the guy's crying he says what's wrong he
says well my next-door neighbor's got
chickens and i'm terrified they're going
to eat me and he says but you know
you're not saved you know you're a human
being and he says i know that but do the
chickens know right
you know i know
like there's there's no ghosts right but
but i but i act as if there is whenever
i hear a creek at night i knew a car
won't make make me more attracted to the
upsex or fulfill me in some
way but the advertisers believe it um
you know we believe through the other
often like you know you might not
believe in santa claus but as long as
your kids believe in santa claus you get
the pleasure of the belief in it right
we're creatures who
can be caught up in stuff so one more
story it's very quickly this guy seamus
who goes to the pub
and he's drinking beer and he always
orders four pints of guinness and then
one day he comes into the pub and he
wears three pints of guinness and the
guy says listen don't mean to pry
sheamus but you always buy four pints of
guinness drink them and then go home
this week you buy three what's going on
oh he says he says i've got a father and
i've got like two brothers um all
different parts of the world and so i
have a drink for my brothers my father
and myself
but he said recently my father passed
away you know so i still have a drink
for the living you know my two brothers
and myself the guy goes oh sorry for
your loss
so anyway she must keeps doing this and
about six months later he buys
two pints of guinness
i says listen i don't want to pry but
something happened to one of your
brothers and sheamus says oh no no he
says no no no he says doctor's orders
i've had to stop drinking right
you know the idea is that you are the
ironic gesture you're doing the very
thing that you don't think you're doing
right we can
think that we're free from this frenetic
pursuit but still be caught up in it
and so what you need to do is in a sense
surround yourself in a liturgical
structure in which people enact that
freedom through comedy and music and
spoken word and we come together and we
create what could be called a task a
temporary autonomous zone a space in
which we live as though we are freed
from this frenetic pursuit just a
theatrical performance i think we we act
as if
and as we leave that space if we do that
every week and every month and we do
that for a long period of time
eventually we find that we can
incarnate it so yeah well come join our
tops it's
sunday symposium dot com you can get on
the wait list right now we'll let you
know as soon as the tickets both free
and paid tickets open up you're welcome
to contribute or you're welcome to
attend for free it's limited to 200
people we're trying to keep this
relatively small at first and so you're
welcome to join us sunday
symposium.com for our added value this
week to wrap things up this book is what
introduced me to schopenhauer and it's
two books in one the wisdom of life and
councils and maxims i'm just going to
read a one-line sentence so we've we've
spent the last three hours talking about
and around chopin hour about misery
about philosophy about pessimism about
trauma and so much more and
what i loved about his work is it
blended the eastern philosophy and the
western philosophy for the first time
and
he seems a bit harsh at first but some
something about that harshness sort of
drew me to it so this is a line from
page 14 of the wisdom of life
men are not influenced by things
but by their thoughts about things
and doesn't that summarize what we talk
about perfectly and can i tell a story
that sums it up i think is that okay or
absolutely we're coming to your clues
are we um
to sum up then schopenhauer just thought
of the stories you're talking about this
guy's shamelessly you may have heard of
he um
thank you uh you know him yeah i met him
you met him yeah well due to an
unfortunate set of circumstances he
finds himself living in los angeles
right oh no yeah oh no
and he finds himself hanging out with a
spiritual community right typical la
spiritual community so they're into
vegan diets raw food they're into
psychedelics and they're into of course
polyamory right um and sheamus finds all
of this interesting but particularly the
polyamory he says you mean i can have a
wife and a girlfriend and they're all
laughing at us shame is going yes
absolutely
he's like oh that's crazy he says i'll
have to talk to my wife about this right
so he goes off and he's away for about
six months he comes back to the
spiritual community and
the leader in a patronizing kind of way
says she almost did you ever talk to
your wife about polyamory he says i did
i did and you know what she was
delighted she loved the idea she says no
i've got a wife and i've got a
girlfriend and the community gathered
ryan they pat him on the back that's
great i said what's your favorite thing
about it oh says sheamus he says it's
great he says now i can tell my wife
that i'm with my girlfriend and my
girlfriend with my wife and i can be
left alone
that's the secret in la there is this
demand to have pleasure and access and
enjoyment and stability of you know a
relationship and the fun of sexual
whatever demand demand demand what she
must find was a way in the whole the god
of the demand to enjoy the god of the
demand to enjoy in l.a find a way to
carve out a space
to just be
that's kind of schuberth in a nutshell
we'll put a link to this book in the
show notes for our final added value
this week
i stumbled across this band on instagram
and they're called dwellers and this
song is called you're gonna cry
and it's really a song about the
fundamental okayness of misery i love
this line from the song
you're gonna cry we're gonna die
but it's all right
and i think that sums up this whole
episode today
so enjoy the song from
dwellers it's called
you're gonna cry or if you're watching
the video version on youtube you can
check out the link somewhere above my
left shoulder by the way we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week on the
private podcast like what are the
dangers of minimalist design how do i
entangle who i am from what i do for a
living how would the minimalists spend
their money if they won the 87 million
dollar lottery plus a million more
questions for peter rollins and the
minimalists and if you want to hear all
that check out the minimalist private
podcast this week visit the
minimalists.com private or click the
link in the description to subscribe and
get your personal link so that our
weekly maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to all of our archives
recordings of live events weekly home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you if you have a question or comment
for our podcast give us a call 406
219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalist.com you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalists to get our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus tk coleman alabama podcast
sean jordan no more professor sean
social chess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team my name is
joshua fields milburn if you leave here
today with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it